[Music]
[Music]
welcome to wisdom for life where we sift
through philosophy to find practical
advice you can use in your everyday life
hi I'm Danny's I'm joined by my co-host
dr. Greg Sadler today we're gonna be
talking about the topic of giving in to
the wrong things and there's a Greek
word for this that we're going to
introduce right away and then we'll
define it later on it's called a cross
iya and we often translate this as
weakness of will or failure to follow
through on things you can also translate
it as a lack or loss of self-control and
it's something that there was a lot of
debate about actually not just in
ancient times but all the way down to
the present some people say that it
doesn't really happen or exists but I
think that we all experience it at one
point or another and what way what do
you think Dan well I have a number of
papers that I wrote at like 3:00 a.m. in
college so yes I think there is
something to it now why why would that
be particularly relevant to lack of
self-control or loss of Kesava control
it sounds like you actually exercised
self-control to get them done right yeah
well at the very end you know when you
have a deadline fast approaching the the
uncomfortableness of that tends to
outweigh the uncomfortableness of not
doing it in the first place you know
I've heard quite a few people over the
years say that they they work better
under deadlines that's usually the
tagline for it right and I don't know
that they actually do better work like
better quality work under the deadlines
but just forced to do it yeah they
actually get it done so something
something external motivates them and
maybe it's fear shame or one of these
other negative emotions you know you can
also I suppose use anger you know I'm
gonna get this thing done by God you
know all right to force yourself like
the problem with doing that is that the
anger also tends to lead you down to
some negative other conclusions while
you're doing that yeah it does that
doesn't make for good writing that's
that's for sure yeah I'm trying to think
of I don't
does I Oh is his name on Hunter s
Thompson seems to have some pretty
decent angry prose I remember his
obituary of Nixon being rather cutting I
don't know if that was from anger or
just from a deep disdain you know I was
just reading something the other day I
got from our local library because we
can do drive up you know pickup and I
actually walked up there because it's
just a few blocks from here at the
Central Library so I'm doing some class
videos about Thoreau's civil
disobedience and so I I got this text
and it's it's called civil disobedience
but it's got a bunch of his other essays
and one of the ones I had never read it
before and I didn't actually know that
that the road written Onix I'm not a
thorough scholar or anything but it's
about John Brown and it was fascinating
to read you know John Brown the the
great abolitionist who led the raid on
Harpers Ferry but for like a decade
before that had been fighting in
Missouri against the the slaveholders
and it was really interesting to read in
part because Thoreau was criticizing not
just the Southerners but also the
northerners first kind of like hanging
this get this guy out to dry you know
they're like he's he's got the right you
know frame of mind but he's also kind of
nuts he's you know monomaniacal about
this he's not willing to compromise and
and Thoreau actually wrote a really
interesting piece in which you can tell
that the RO is angry with his own
contemporaries but it's kind of a
measured thing it's you know he's not
just writing you know one just sitting
down and knocking it out in one one
single session I think there's kind of a
you know a measure to it but it's still
it's it's very clear that he is he's
upset about the fact that people want to
write this person off who seems to have
you know had a lot of admirable
qualities mm-hmm once again reminds me
of the letter from a Birmingham jail
with MLK saying oh the moderates
the white moderates you know well in
good time in due time we'll we'll get to
this like no the time is now like you
know I equal rights doesn't weights or
should not be waiting
yeah you too I mean feel good about it
we're not getting into the the topic yet
but I think that is a really important
point that when it comes down to matters
of doing the right thing it's almost
never the right time because there's
almost always people there to say no no
let's let's look at this in another way
let's be reasonable or you know don't
aren't you worried about your reputation
or what might happen to you know your
your your profession or your business or
you know there's there's a million
reasons not to act right right and so
and going back to the whole idea of the
procrastination as this yeah yeah on the
idea here should but that went off for a
bit or oh I totally yeah let's go to the
next stop at here and we'll come back to
it eventually
no go ahead with procrastination on a
internal versus external locus of
control and this is just like locusts or
Center on and that's like are you doing
things because you are the one that's
actually motivating you to do things or
are you doing things because other
people have put pressure on you to do
that like I see its became actually a
really big problem here and with the
kovat and walk down and that out now you
don't have it you don't have to go into
work and you don't have that like you
know Oh yet to be there at 9:00 a.m. or
8:00 a.m. or 5 a.m. depending on what
it's like you do your job when you do
your job and now how how do you make
sure that you do your work and and I
feel like it's caused a lot of people to
either sink or swim to develop an
internal locus of control or not and
maybe they're they're having our trouble
retaining their jobs and this new amount
of office environment it's interesting
because the response was some employers
has been to say we need to install
software to make sure that people are
actually doing what they say that
they're doing is they're working room
and and you know okay so there there's
probably some people abusing the time
and multitasking and all that but then
again you know we also tend to try to
squeeze every little drop of
productivity out of out of employees a
bit more than we ought to and you know
having something like that coming in is
actually going to be detrimental to
developing an internal locus of control
right because it's just you know Big
Brother boss watching you then I suppose
there's no it's all internal at that
point I'm sorry it's it's not internal
it's it's all external yeah and
especially if you're talking about
knowledge workers and someone on that
it's not you're not like not working if
you're not like turning that widget
every second of the day yeah you know
our idea of a office especially like
pushing paper and whatnot or all of that
is kind of an out push from our factory
total Taylor right management that sort
of thing and yeah and so yeah you're
working if your butts in the seats even
though as we know about offices before
Co vid very few people are actually
getting much done
oh yeah like 60% of the time is not
actually productive time and so it makes
more sense to actually have an output
metric it's like okay we would like you
to do this what stuff and you can either
do it really fast or you can do it
really slow it's up to you and I think
that's a much better metric instead of
like are you looking at the screen for
eight hours a day yeah yeah I mean the
idea of being forced to look at a screen
eight hours a day just is such a big
turn-off for me anyway you know again if
we stick on this topic before we come
back to the Achrafieh thing I kind of
think that if you're in any sort of
knowledge or creative work and I'm
willing to extend that very broadly to
like say just writing insurance reports
about accidents or something like that
everybody needs some time to think
things over and
ruminate and I don't want to say
necessarily daydream you know about like
it's a winning the lottery or something
like that but but at least some down
time during the time that they're
supposed to be productive and that
allows them to be I think more
productive you know this this needing to
have all these these benchmarks met
every single hour or something like that
I think actually hinders productivity
when it comes to we are not automata
yeah yeah although as we were talking
about a few episodes ago maybe will be
replaced by more productivity yes all
right so let's let's talk about this our
ASEA thing so as I mentioned it's it's
kind of a puzzle and ancient literature
and it continues down to the present and
it has to do with a pretty common
experience that we have so if we know
what the right thing to do is or you
know we know right from wrong why don't
we why doesn't that knowledge bring us
to automatically doing it you know
what's wrong with us are we stupid are
we you know perverse are we misguided
and so in in ancient Greece there was a
big I won't say debate about this
because it's more like one person brings
forth one set of ideas and then a couple
years later somebody else brings forth
another set of ideas I don't think they
actually like you know got in the forum
and so I'm gonna talk about you know
across the I'm gonna say there is no
such thing but they there are different
viewpoints and it has to do with these
these experiences that we're all
familiar with like making a commitment
to do something that you know is right
or good or needed or useful and then not
following through it like writing the
paper right it's useful for getting the
grade which is useful for getting the
degree and it's it's important and you
don't want to let yourself down or your
professor down and yet you wait until 3
in the morning to start the paper or
being tempted in a situation to not do
something that you you know you should
do or do something that you shouldn't
and then giving into it like you know
going to the gym and you know you feel a
little tired so you're like I'm not
gonna do all my sets you know or you do
a set and you're like
I don't have to do 12 reps 10 is fine
I'll just I'll just call that a full set
but you know you shouldn't do that right
or having a couple different options in
front of you and you know option a is
the best option and for some reason you
pick option B what is going on there and
we often will say things like oh I know
I shouldn't do this but this one time
it's okay or you know it's my birthday
or it's been a long week or you know I
need to do this in order to get myself
ready for the week ahead you know
there's a million different excuses
right rationalizing it in some way and
we should probably make this decision as
Aristotle does of what is a good
rationalization what's a bad
rationalization yeah yeah you can you
can use the the tricks of the trade of
rhetoric to to get you to the outcome
that you have decided that you wanted
but it might not be actually a good
reason to do so yeah that's a really
good point just because one can come up
with a plausible set of reasons doesn't
mean that those are actually good
reasons or or you know that they they
fit the the situation at a you know and
I kind of think that people when they
tell themselves these things over and
over again like oh you know it's it's
because it's Friday and I need to unwind
you do that often enough and that
becomes a habit you know and not just a
habit of behavior a habit of you
actually saying that very same thing
well it's just Friday so I don't want to
think anymore yeah yeah so I guess to
bring out the first formation of this
question I believe is from the Meno I'm
Socrates is having a dialogue with you
know and basically makes the conclusion
that people do only what they think is
the good and they only do bad things
because they are mistaken by what the
good really is yeah they think they're
doing something good when they're
actually doing something bad and if they
had if they had fuller knowledge about
it then they they wouldn't do that bad
thing and it comes up in
in the Protagoras and in other dialogues
as well and it's a it's a pretty
consistent message and you know we have
all the reason in the world to think
that Socrates actually thought and
taught this people and what do you think
about that idea do you buy that I I buy
that for a lot of things it's definitely
not a every every situation falls into
this ok um and so I guess uh I I bought
into it more I had an early point in my
life but I
oh that's interesting why just because
it it I guess intuitively it made a lot
of sense and it died with some other
observations and then as I got more and
more familiar with the full extent of
the philosophical conversation happening
between him Plato and Aristotle that it
was like okay they're actually making
really good points and we need to you
know carve out a section of this where
these things don't apply because you
know as I think I spoke about last week
we're not home economicus we're not
always rational purely you know
beneficial beings sometimes we do things
that are very plainly irrational yeah I
think I also can say that a younger
version of myself was more attracted to
that idea that the basic problem is of
ignorance that you know it's it's and
and for those of us who do know the good
then because we all assume that you know
we're the ones who know that what the
good is then it's up to us to educate or
argue or whatever it is to get to these
people to see what the genuine good is
and it led me to a lot of conflicts and
irritation and and you know a lot is
doing the right thing it's so plain or
I'll tell you yeah yeah that and and and
you get mad at people when when you're
like you're just not getting it and when
you start to realize the reasons why
people aren't getting it
I think there's two ways you can go you
can be like see that's why you're a bad
person or you can say oh man that's that
really sucks to be in that position
where you can't actually see right from
wrong now when you say that to people
they they're not usually very receptive
to that though right and so you know
being able to for me I guess you can say
being able to take a more Aristotelian
position on these sorts of things has
actually made for a better life for for
me and I have also come to recognize to
where I was the one who was mistaken
about things and doing something bad
thinking on some level it was good but
also you know doing doing bad things
knowing full well that they are bad but
being giving in at that point in time or
having some you know mistaken set of
dynamics going on or allowing so yeah
because you want to describe the
aristotelian position here or do you we
want to first hit what Plato was well
let's talk about Plato first because
he's kind of a bridge point right so in
the Republic and in the Phaedrus he he
puts out an idea of the human being as
not being one single unified thing but
actually having parts to our personality
or soul and one part is rational and we
ought to listen to that provided it's
not been corrupted and then we have the
appetites you know for food and drink
and sex and all sorts of other things
and these are desires they steer us
towards things they they make us want to
just lay around and eat chips and do
nothing all day and watch Netflix way
into the night binge watching a show you
know not realizing the network should
watch the nice girls walk by and they're
sure summer dresses or whatever yeah
yeah it was it was that a violent FEM
sighing the other thing is there I'm
thinking actually on painted black by
the Rolling Stones I think it's the
stones yeah yeah maybe it's that orders
yeah I was just thinking you know what
could what song
no no painted black I think is is there
really yeah yeah I see those girls doing
all the things that were
we're not really supposed to do that's
what the appetites want us to do right
and enter the uh she uses the analogy of
the charioteer here correct
yeah well that's in the Phaedrus you get
the two horses one's a good horse one's
a bad horse and the bad horse wants to
pull you off off in all sorts of
directions a good horse wants to go
along the noble path and then the
charioteer the poor guy is reason
alright but in the Republic it's just
these three parts that are kind of
arranged in relation to each other and
the middle part that gets angry and is
concerned with honor that's the part
that really makes all the difference
because because rationality will tell us
what to do but by itself it can't make
the desires fall into line so you know
it's kind of an interesting idea about
about things I don't know that we have
to buy into it altogether but what we do
get there is that the possibility of
being led astray by our desires knowing
what the right thing to do is but being
powerless to to enact it unless we we
will or choose to do so it almost seems
like a yes and answer to Socrates is
like yes you know steeple can have the
correct idea of what the good is and a
incorrect idea of what the good is but
there's another thing that's also there
that's influencing this yeah actually
that that's a good way to put it and in
in the Republic he does talk about
there's this interesting argument where
he says how do we know that there are
parts to the soul because otherwise the
soul would would be doing all just one
thing if it can have conflict you know
if the parts can if the if we could have
different themes different being tugged
in different directions
there must be different faculties
different operations going on I kind of
buy that you know I don't know that
there's three I think there's probably
more than that but you know yeah now if
we follow our brothers sorry no go ahead
oh you know something I'd like to get to
you later
that we might go into it right now is
it's like it's a good idea okay so on
some of the more contemporary philosophy
of mind touches on these in a very
interesting way and the one that I like
is this modular theory of mind which
depending on a what philosopher that
you're reading on has slightly different
variables to it but the two main guys
are Jerry Fodor and Peter her others and
I'm kind of the the basic idea for a
modular theory of mind is that we have
on within our brains uh-oh
at least at like neurotypical and at
like births or like at least through the
the normal stage of development there
are certain portions of our brains that
are modular and are for certain things
for example like the visual cortex is
for the most part it processes the
visual images from our eyes and produces
some picture that our conscious mind can
understand and they extend these - okay
there's like a fear response and there's
like a on a reproductive respond sir
there's a hunger response and these
things aren't entirely individual
sometimes some are subsumed within
others and sometimes they are like you
know been diagrams via partly Cheryl and
overlapping yeah and that's the the
decision that is eventually made by the
conscious mind is the that module that
basically yells the loudest within the
the mind like the idea of like you look
at mmm our eyes you see which areas
light up the most and you know it's it's
still this is you know cutting-edge
science at least to try to and verify
these particular positions but they're
they're making a philosophical like we
think this is how the mind works you
know maybe not but it seems to fit the
criteria for the information that we
currently have but you know this doesn't
also uh
I removed from the ability that our
brain is plastic and we have lots of
experiences of people losing large
chunks of their brain and their brain
has been able to remap on you know motor
functions and all sorts of things to
places where they were you would not
find it in a neurotypical individual
yeah you know it's interesting I have a
friend who's a psychotherapist and he
was talking about working with trauma
patients and you know he was he was
discussing if you it was not just trauma
patients he also trains other
psychologists and he was trying to get
them to see that if everything is gonna
be essentially an amygdala response you
know you're kind of you can't do much
right because you're gonna be stuck in
these very fixed sets of responses if
we're talking about decision-making the
decision-making is going to be very
constricted so you have to find ways to
draw a person out of out of that sort of
like almost automatically going down to
that that level in order to be able to
start to make make progress and he was
pointing out too that you know this
isn't just a matter for patients this is
also a matter for the psychologists or
psychiatrists or you know social workers
themselves because they're attempted to
do that sort of thing as well when they
encounter somebody who's like you say
yelling at them in a session you know so
yeah I think there's there's quite a bit
to recommend that you know the modular
thing to I was thinking about this with
with the play-doh just to throw this out
there as a little aside friedrich
nietzsche looked at the human person as
essentially being it's sort of in a
modular way except you know we've got
kind of a hierarchy of different
interconnected things and the instead of
it being the one that shouts the loudest
he would say the one with the greatest
quanta of will is the one that that that
runs the show but we're all according to
him kind of a mess of different stuff
that's all kind of cobbled together and
hanging together
and there's never gonna be any complete
unity to it but we think we're unified
all the time and that's kind of an
interesting you know I think he's partly
right about that we're not we're
definitely not as unified as a lot of
the let's call it pop psychology or folk
psychology models of the human person
make us out to be a little homunculus in
our heads yeah I mean I think unity is
kind of like an ideal rather than
something we can automatically assume
about human beings yeah we're kind of
messy yeah so another thing that
actually turns is practical is that we
do know that like the way that we learn
things is through repeated like if
you're if you want to like really learn
something usually you go over over and
over and over again and that every time
that you on go through the same pathways
the brain actually builds up those
pathways makes them stronger there's
like Portugal where they add extra fat
molecules in order to increase oh really
yeah it increases the the insulation of
fat down he increases the insulation so
that the the by electrical signals can
go through those process those pathways
with less segregation interesting yeah
so on this is the idea is whatever
modules that you allow to make your
decisions for you the more apt you're
going to go down those same pathways in
future and so so if you want to keep
making the same say right decision over
and over again you need to keep
practicing that in a variety of
situations right right but if you keep
if you if you give in to the wrong
decisions over and over again it makes
it more difficult to get out of them
yeah okay that I mean that jives really
well with with where we're gonna be
going and just a couple minutes of
Aristotle actually so I think we should
talk about Aristotle then okay so so
Aristotle
is you know in a certain way you could
say that he's like one of the first at
least in his time scientific
psychologists he he devotes a bit more
attention from a kind of experiential
phenomenological perspective than I
think Socrates or Plato did and and he
provides us with a more nuanced way of
looking at all of this so he thinks that
it's it's true that there is there's
this weakness of will or failure that we
call a cross yeah and that it's
different from other moral dispositions
so it's not the same thing as having a
vise a bad character trait that is
become ingrained in you it's not the
same thing as just making a mistake it's
not the same thing as being placed in
forced situations where you you just
have to pick you know the least of the
the evils and it's not the same thing as
like being damaged in the sense of like
having some sort of organic damage or or
illness or having been traumatized or
anything like that instead you've got a
person who's you know more or less
capable of making the right decisions
but they just don't
and so then you gotta ask well why and
he says well the what's going on
fundamentally is that there's a conflict
between parts of ourselves there's
there's the rational part or at least
you know a deliberative choice part that
we call prior ASIS and and that's that's
on to what should be the right thing I
mean it could still be wrong and then
you've got these desires or appetites or
sometimes it's it's that that other part
that we are talking about is the
spirited part of the soul you know
wanting you to go beat somebody up or
respond or retaliate and and there's a
conflict and one's saying let's do this
the others saying no no let's do this
instead and you you give in to the one
that's lower in the schema and there's
an opposite to this which is what he
calls n Crotty I meaning self-control
it's literally self mastery being being
in charge of yourself and these are you
so here's where it gets really
interesting with the neural pathways
stuff those are in between virtue and
vice the virtuous person finds it fairly
easy to do the right thing they're
naturally oriented towards it so if
we're thinking in terms of this this you
know sort of physical brain state stuff
they've got the right neural pathways
well-established and all what did you
say like they there's their fat
insulated okay so so the virtuous person
is built up kind of a nexus of this and
the vicious person is built up another
nexus in between them are lack of self
control and self control and the person
who is self controlled doesn't yet love
you know doing the virtuous thing but
they know it's the right thing to do and
they make themself do it so if we're
thinking about like temperance you know
an example that that you and I have
kicked around a lot before is like when
you go to the all-you-can-eat buffet
really you shouldn't eat all you can eat
you should lay down some limits you know
maybe four plates as is getting to the
extreme especially if you're gonna have
like two desserts afterwards because you
want to get your money's worth right so
maybe you should only have three plates
and a soup and one dessert and even
that's kind of pushing it right so you
know if you're self controlled you say
stop at that point even though you want
to have more where as the the lack of
self control or the uncontrolled person
is gonna find some reason why that night
they should have five plates and two
desserts and three soups and I don't
know exactly yeah yeah and they mate and
they may use that well I've paid for it
so I have to get my money's worth trying
as as an excuse but once you get your
money's worth you might be paying for it
a second time later when you are feeling
very uncomfortable due to you are very
very full belly that's a good point and
and you pay for another coin as well I
mean it's not it's not good for you
physically to be eating more than you
ought to so there's a cumulative effect
over time you're also sort of damaging
your yourself in terms of your
self-control the next time that you go
in right and so this is interesting that
like Aristotle's very much like oh you
got a got to teach your kids right early
on very holy and so this kind of makes
sense
like if you can hope to instill certain
things early on it makes a lot easier
for them to actually do those good
things going forward into your their
lights because they've created habits of
doing virtuous things and not so many
vicious things yeah I think from
Aristotle's perspective many of us were
kind of screwed early on and we're lucky
that we've made as much of ourselves as
we have he knew about Aristotle for it
actually also Newton knew about
Nietzsche too it's funny that you bring
up Freud because my students whenever I
teach them about Plato's tripartite soul
they've always somewhere heard about
Freud and learned about the the in the
super-ego and the ego and this triatic
relation that Freud has and they'll say
oh well Plato's basically just like
Freud and I'll say well the the it and
the appetites okay I can see that
they're they're kind of similar right
the appetites can't control themselves
neither can the it'd but the the
rational part of the soul if if the
rational part of the soul is a super-ego
you're you're in a lot of trouble you
know and and if the thematic part is
your ego again you're gonna have some
problems so they they map on at the
lower part but they don't map on at the
higher part yeah I was thinking more
about the like everything's from
childhood trauma oh yeah a lot of his
with Aristotle it's less about trauma
it's more about bad habits right but
that's that's actually a great question
I mean Aristotle this is a bit of a
digression but he does distinguish
another state that he calls brutality or
morbid dispositions and he of course he
says barbarians are like this you know
look at them eating raw flesh over there
and
on the though you know the Black Sea and
but one of the things that he brings up
and he's very specific about this is
abuse of children and he says that this
can damage a person so much that you
can't even say that they're vicious
because in the vicious person that
rational part of their soul is there
it's just corrupted it's been screwed up
in some way in a brutalized person it's
been like so thoroughly damaged that it
doesn't really have much much role at
all and and the person is reduced to the
level of just animality but human
animality is worse than regular animals
because there there ought to be
something else there for us you know
that would regulate things so that kind
of comes to like there's definitely a
large component of the environment in
which someone is raised that will create
the the habits of how they will be
dealing with things but then you know if
someone really it's like oh we could
just like save all the kids or something
by throwing them into like really nice
schools then you get like kind of
atrocities like you saw with the Native
American population here in the United
States and them you know trying to
westernize and by stealing them away
from their parents putting them into
boarding schools and preventing them
from speaking their languages yeah
losing losing that connection to the
people that you've bonded with early on
and you know losing a language by what
you do that that is that is really a
terrible trauma and Salinas people
thinking about their doing is the right
thing the good thing to make these
people better but they're actually you
know once again it goes back to them
yeah and it goes back to the Plato or
sorry the Socrates of like they think
they know it's right but they don't
actually know what's right yeah you know
it's it's interesting when things like
that happen you can say to yourself well
why don't you know that that's right
you know and sometimes people will say
oh well we can't criticize people of the
past because you know different times
different mores different ideas about
things we don't want to be inaccurate
but historians will point out over and
over again that almost every time that
that we see something like that being
done as a norm there's somebody who's
like this is this is bad you should not
be doing this you know there there's
always social critics resisting that in
some way and pointing out that that that
isn't the only possible way and I think
that's that's actually one of the really
valuable things about history is
bringing those other voices back to life
you know to bring this back to what we
were talking about before there were a
lot of people at the you know around the
time of the civil war who were like
listen you know a slavery terrible thing
but you know it's much more important
that we keep the Union together or that
we have compromises about this or that
you know well weed it out over a couple
generations and somebody like John Brown
came around and said listen you know God
told me that this is wrong and I'm just
gonna pursue this you know and then he's
looked at as a complete madman if he if
he I suppose if he'd said something like
you know I have a logically deductive
argument for why this is wrong and he
didn't bring God into the picture maybe
he wouldn't have been seen as as crazy
but or maybe he would but there was also
lots of use of religion to 2:02
perpetuates yeah yeah yeah so and so
John Brown is is a great example of
somebody who didn't just like go with
the mores of his time he was like this
is definitely wrong you know the early
Republicans who you know we know the
Radical Republicans were founded here in
Wisconsin in Milwaukee well written I
think right oh where the head is the
first thing I thought there was a plaque
downtown that says like this is like
maybe was like the first like official
convention or something that very well
could be because this is the most
important city and and we had quite a
few anti-slavery people come out of out
of Milwaukee but yeah but so I mean with
any with anything you can find somebody
to say yeah this is this isn't the right
thing to do and maybe maybe there's like
even in totalitarian societies where one
of
the things that's that's key to them is
like driving the conscience out of
people and and making it almost
impossible for them to speak up there's
still some people who are like yep this
is wrong you shouldn't do this so so we
do have you know some possibility of
gaining knowledge about what's right and
wrong available to us much of the time
we just often ignore it
right and it seems like we're in one of
those inflection points where certain
things are definitely becoming oh well
enough people have decided this is wrong
that we're actually going to make it
wrong yeah and and that's something that
I have guarded optimism about you know I
think if I were 20 years younger I'd be
very optimistic but I think you know
when you look back over history you see
how easy it is for for things that are
on the right track to fall apart or to
go in the wrong direction but if you
look at like for example on South Africa
oh shoot he was just on Mandela was a
political prisoner on Robben Island and
20 years later he's the leader of the
country yeah then the most racist you
know basis of government in the entire
world to having a black president that's
that's an amazing turnaround yeah and I
think that another thing that we can say
about Mandela too was his commitment to
not engaging and this is where he ends
up breaking with his wife and the ANC as
well not a commitment to not pursuing
sort of a okay we're on top now
everybody's gonna suffer under us kind
of kind of strategy that you see like
happening you know almost next door in
Zimbabwe under the mcgaubey regime still
still with its effects going on today
yeah you know I mean we're again we're
getting far from our topic but we could
say that in a lot of cases political
leaders have to struggle with this issue
of self control as well
you know we see nowadays this oh go
ahead do you do the things that you
think will get you powered you do the
things that you think will actually be
right and there's that that stronghold
to just you know oh yeah I can say the
most vile things because it's definitely
gonna rile up my base
whichever way and and you know but is
that actually going to produce the the
good rule the you know a functioning
government that actually provides the
services that you know we as modulus
expect from that yeah you know I think
to that so there's that there's the like
you know demagoguery wait we call that
but I think there's another challenge
for politicians as well which is become
they say I'm and I get into this and I'm
gonna change the system from within and
then there's all these decisions where
like well if you want to move up you
gotta like you know do a favor for this
person and do a favor for this person
it's at the expense of somebody else and
it's usually unjust in some way and I
think there's probably a you know it the
best way to get somebody to do that of
course is you like get them a little bit
drunk and then get them into a back room
and you say you need to make a decision
about this now because you know what
side are you on
I think there's a lot of tendencies
towards across yeah when it comes to
those sorts of little compromises you
know and I think you can extend that as
well to education and to the corporate
world there's this tendency to cut
corners and you know make things easier
for oneself even when one knows that on
some level it's wrong and if you do so
long enough it becomes you know second
nature we're such social creatures that
like you know someone only comes up to
you say oh yeah you got the power and
we're friends and you just do this
little thing it's not much and and
that's that's that first little step
that chinks away at what you you know
your ideals are you know man and then
you give in a little bit more and more
and I guess it snowballs they don't want
to make a slippery slope argument though
you know when I was teaching in in
Indiana State Prison it was very
important not to accept any favors from
a prisoner even to the point of
they give you a candy don't accept the
candy and you don't do anything outside
of the the bounds of what your the scope
of your job is for prisoners either and
the reason is because there is a
slippery slope and and it's not all of
them I mean that I actually met some
really great people while I was teaching
in the prison but I also met some some
other people who were much more
questionable and I met a few people
where the other prisoners would say I
hope that guy never gets out because he
scares the hell out of me you know and
but it was the middle ground of the
prisoners that you had to really watch
out for because if you do a you know if
you do this favor then there's two
things going on they'll say well if you
did that favor why won't you do this
favor it's reasonable for you to do that
and that if you don't do it then they'll
also say well if you don't do that favor
for me I'm gonna reveal that you also
did this favor and then you're gonna get
in trouble so there's a push-pull and
this is how we get people you know
carrying in cell phones and bags of
marijuana so it's a crazy stuff or
you're like what the hell went wrong
with this you know engaging in in
trafficking and I don't think you have
to just look at prisons in order to see
that there are many people willing to
take advantage of our across eeya you
know if right if we allow ourselves to
be a kradic some of them just you know
it's not so personally motivated but
some of them will get their hooks into
you and just keep going and going and
going yeah it's it's gotta be a I know I
guess a high-pressure teaching
environment it's hard to deal with Oh in
a prison yeah you know it that's
interesting because once you establish a
reputation for not being readily
corruptible you don't have to be like
pretend to be incorruptible and be then
you know Man of Steel or something like
that
it's just like any other things
security-oriented your your house
doesn't have to be a castle it just has
to be more visibly secure than the house
next door and they won't break into your
house you know so I think you can say
that about people's reputations as well
once once people realize nah
this guy isn't gonna take a candy from
from me or do me a little favor there's
no point in trying they're not gonna
waste their time and it's not like they
respect you because of that it's more
just you know you're not a mark right so
do you want to hit one more topic you're
good of the question yeah so I do want
to talk about one other thing with
Aristotle he he thinks that there's a
number of different things that we can
be Latin we can have a lack of
self-control about and and I don't think
his list is exhaustive but I think it is
quite interesting how he breaks it down
he thinks that you know pleasure and
pain like trying to avoid pain and
trying to get things that we find
pleasant is is like the core meaning of
a crash yeah but the other things where
we have a lack or loss of self control
that he lists are these anger and this
is where he actually he likes makes it
makes an argument that well across here
with respect to anger not so bad as with
respect to pleasure because anger at
least is rational you know that's a
little bit debatable love of victory or
success
philony kia in in greek okay Nakia is or
nikkei yeah and so beating other people
right when we want to be right when we
want to go faster than other people or
we want to be celebrated even if we're
actually wrong we want to to be the one
who's acknowledged as successful money
of course you know that's kind of a
common thing there's algorithm yeah
except in this case it's not it's not
the vice of avarice it's just a cry it's
just a lack of self-control when it
comes to this and if you keep giving in
to it you will become avaricious ah but
you're not yet there you know you're
like well I should go to my kids
recitals but there is this side gig you
know and I do feel bad about it whereas
the vicious person is like bass squier
the kids recital you know everybody's
got to earn as much money as possible
you know talk to the kid recitals don't
pay for your braces something like that
but then the other thing that he says
that's really interesting kids and
parent
now think about how many people you know
they're pretty decent people but when it
comes to their kids they will like do
all sorts of underhanded things to
advance their kids who we usually aren't
aren't worth worth advancing or they'll
do this for parents or they'll do this
for other family members or friends or
other relationships and see is one
portion of that is like the living the
buy carry through that's wise and and
they see your children as an extension
of yourself and you know willing to do
what needs to be done to get ahead and
extending that to your children yeah
that's a good that's a good yeah like
what is it the the recent ish scandal of
like getting kids into college yeah yeah
now I think some of those people were
really vicious because they were like
this is what everybody does you know I
didn't do anything wrong here the ones
that were actually saying yeah yeah I
know I shouldn't do this but it's my kid
they could be said to be a kradic yeah
as well as the people facilitating that
would also be definitely be big ones who
took the bribes yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's an interesting day may have been
a kradic the first time it's like oh you
know it's like I'm hard up for money or
something and I have this access and
well like one little thing one little
favor is not going to you know kill me
but you know once you do it it becomes a
little bit easier to do and yeah and and
it might have been tied into with like
you're a little bit starstruck because
this is a famous person or somebody
who's got some real pull and while
they're paying attention to me that they
invited me out to their beach house or
you know out on their yacht now they're
not and then they're they're giving me
the the pitch right yeah that's a great
example yeah I you know I patted your
back you want to pat my back you know
yeah yeah good for that because if they
if they won't pat your back then you can
push them off the side because of the
implication
[Laughter]
aha okay so we have a question here hey
so I have an essay I need to write and
it's pretty personal so it's already
tough to write but I have procrastinated
for a week already and I feel intensely
guilty about the fact that I wasted all
this time
whenever I start trying to write I just
feel extremely guilty and anxious and so
I start browsing reddit instead to
de-stress the worst thing is there's no
deadline so the panic from the deadline
can't overcome the negative Billings and
force me to do it I just need to finish
this as soon as possible preferably
today do you have any suggestions and
how I can overcome this guilt and start
working that's a good one there's two
things there right there's the whole
procrastination thing but then there's
how do I deal with the guilt mm-hmm so
you have some thoughts on this one right
um the first one is just a you know a
simple method that I found to be very
useful and like the biggest hurdle with
procrastination from my experience as
well as you know from what I have read
out there as solutions is just getting
started and you sit there and you make
every excuses like oh well you know oh I
can do the dishes and so you go do the
dishes you know they sit down you're
like and I could fold my clothes and you
go and fold your clothes and you come
back and the dog needs to go for a walk
and and I need to take a shower just
like oh but it's now it's bedtime so
I'll just do this in the morning on and
the idea is to take you know if you see
it I've got a little timer here little
kitchen timer and you just put it for 15
minutes it's the Pomodoro method um you
say I'm gonna write for 15 minutes and
you don't stop writing for 15 minutes
and once you've done that for 15 minutes
I'm then you you can go on to the rest
of it it's just idea this this giant
insurmountable thing and you're breaking
it down to oh I can definitely write for
15 minutes that's easy I can do that
that's true and once once you've gotten
started oftentimes it can it can go much
much more smoothly although another
thing that a lot of writers have
problems with is they write something
and then they immediately start self
editing self criticizing and that's not
a good thing to do either right when I'm
working with with people I always say
write more than you need because then
you can trim it you know don't don't
like say oh this is garbage I'm not
going to put this down on paper because
that just stops you right you know you
want to get into that zone flow States
just just right I guess that I have been
in and that is really enjoyable when I
would write student papers I would now
back then I was I was smoking so I would
like get myself a couple packs of
cigarettes or I'd roll up a whole bunch
of cigarettes and then I'd start making
pots of coffee and I'd have all my like
research materials piled up around me
and I just start writing you know and
I'd put some music on - and I would I
would just go and it might take me eight
hours it might take me 24 hours but I
would at the end of it have a pretty
polished paper but not completely you
know you just get it to the point where
you've got your thoughts down and then I
would crash go to sleep for maybe 24
hours then get up and then start doing
all the you know making it look nice and
stuff now that's not a great way to do
things as you get older yeah I can no
longer do all-nighters they they kill me
now yeah I know yes the other question
is about the guilt correct yeah yeah so
what do you think about that um well
like those things that happen in the
past or in the past they are immutable
unchangeable and the only thing that
they're good for is to be a lesson for
you on either what to do or what not to
do in the present moment and so if you
can just let go over the past and say I
have a task in front of me I don't need
to worry about the anything that's
happened the past I can't change it if
that actually you know that's like
theory and you have to actually like
practice that to you know try to you
know put this thought into action though
you know I think too with guilt
you have to ask well guilty towards whom
you know guilt is something that we feel
relationally it's it's not just
something that we have and if it doesn't
have any sort of you're guilty because
you're worried about what's so-and-so
might think of you and you also feel may
be guilty in relation to yourself like
you let yourself down and so yeah that
what you're saying is is is really
helpful maybe thinking about did you
really let yourself down is this is this
something that you could you know
recuperate by actually doing it that
that might might be helpful as well you
know the other thing I was going to say
too so if you don't want to be a
Craddock it's probably good to cut down
on temptations and this might be one of
the biggest temptations when you're
writing because we've got all these apps
at our fingertips just I know of us that
are not on the video you salting up and
cell phone yeah exactly and and I think
that you know I myself I I struggle with
this it's it's too easy to go and look
at what's going on on Twitter or what's
happening on Facebook or did somebody
say something on one of my videos or you
know checking the news or looking at
email or any of those sorts of things it
might be good to put your cell phone in
another room you know you can put it on
and so if somebody calls you on the
phone or text so you can hear it back
that might be one distraction that you
have to put a sound and there there's
probably other distractions to you
mentioned what cleaning up the house
yeah take a dog for a walk when you're
in the midst of hardcore procrastination
you will find the most boring mundane
things and that is going to be the most
exciting thing you've ever done
ah but I think we need to move on to our
practice yeah
so do you want to you want to lead us
through this er I can do so one of the
things that you can do when you're
finding yourself not getting things done
not not doing what you ought to do is
taking a matter in which you want to
develop more self control luckily could
be the buffet it could be going to the
gym and doing all of your your exercises
it could be calling a person who you're
supposed to have called a while ago and
then didn't and now feel guilty about or
anything along these lines and when
you're in that situation you remind
yourself that this is this is this is a
chance that you have you give a goal and
this is a matter that does tempt you by
struggling against it here and now
you're not just doing it for here and
now you're helping yourself in the
future so there's there's kind of a
stake that your you're dealing with and
you can't just say to yourself oh it's
just this little thing here this little
thing here you can tell yourself I am
actually helping to establish better
habits for myself and you and you might
not used it as a mantra you could say by
choosing the right thing now I'm
choosing for myself later on and if you
do that you know in one thing you'll
learn how to do that and then you can
transfer that to other things as well
so if you can learn how to I don't know
wash the dishes when when they're
sitting in the sink instead of letting
them just keep piling up or what are
other things that we struggle with
[Music]
what's your biggest goodness or weakness
um let's see they say you're not reading
the news okay
yeah like I'll actually write that down
on my planners like don't read the news
until at least afternoon because I know
that it is something that I'm drawn
towards and and it becomes negative both
emotionally and mentally and yeah it's
not good for me but I do so when you dry
yourself in or when you when you when
you do that you can say okay I'm setting
myself a pattern for
this and then you can transfer that to
whatever the next thing is right and
another way to look at this is like ways
of reframing yeah good and for example
you can say is like oh oh why physically
look at it it's like a video game that
you have all these times that you have
as examples of like okay I have a goal
and I have time Suk's to try to get this
thing right and it's okay if I fail as
long as I know I'm still progressing
towards that goal or I guess I'm William
Irvine brought out a book not too long
ago called the stoic challenge which
talks about reframing and his added
reframing instantly they've got like
some sort of you know stoic God you know
regardless if you think it exists or not
but he is putting challenges in front of
you as a test so it's like he's saying
here's the test and if you make it
through it you've become a better person
it sounds good so we've got to end yeah
so we've got lead us out final words
from William Somerset Monty
self-control might be as passionate and
as active as the surrender of Japan
[Music]
you
you